hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we start
morning spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american superhero crime and drama movie
called sleight the story will focus on a young
street magician named beau wolf by day beau
performs magic tricks all over los angeles
with his specialty as being able to control
anything metal even floated in the air
at one time there is a young woman
who was amazed by his magic tricks
because of this beau manages to get acquainted
with the woman learning her name which is holly
when she asks how he could do the trick bo just
remains silent because a magician always keeps his
secret based on the magician's ethics he knows and
also never does the same trick over and over again
meanwhile it turns out that beau has to take care
of his little sister tina sadly their parents
passed away a few years ago this leaves beau
having to do illegal activities to keep a roof
over their heads strangely he apparently did the
trick not using an ordinary tool but by building
an electromagnet into his arm with the negative
electrode of the battery running to his thumb and
the positive electrode running to his fingers
he first developed the electromagnet in high
school for a science project which earned him an
engineering scholarship but he had to turn it down
in order to take care of tina after his parents
died however there is a side effect it seems like
he has to clean his pus that appears every time
he also has to replace the battery with a new one
by night he does not have the life of a normal
teenager he is forced to sell drugs overnight to
pay the bills it is his main source of income
every day with his many base clients he even
almost gets caught by the police when he finishes
selling the drugs but fortunately he still has not
been caught until now when he checks the money he
got from his magic tricks he finds holly's phone
number on a piece of paper since long ago he works
with his supplier named angelo who is usually nice
to him beau is ordered by him to investigate a new
kingpin who comes in and starts selling drugs for
cheaper on their turf after that beau immediately
comes to a club managed by bo's friend luna where
the new kingpin has his dealers selling the drugs
there he pretends to ask one of the dealers for
drugs and he manages to get the dealer's cell
phone using his pickpocketing skills as a magician
he immediately looks up his call history and finds
out that his supplier's name is maurice the next
day beau decides to date holly thanks to the phone
number that he found last night after they chat
for a while he receives a call from angelo telling
him to come to their base it turns out that angelo
has found where maurice lives currently they
plan to invade maurice's house on the other hand
beau is given a gun for self-defense later
although he is reluctant to get involved
in this plan at first because he is basically
the type of person who does not like violence
arriving there they directly catch maurice
including his men at first they offer cooperation
instead of being hostile as they are now but
because one of maurice's men underestimates
him angelo is annoyed and immediately hits him as
he tells them to think about his offer carefully
the next morning beau does his magic as usual
which makes the people around him even more amazed
while he is having dinner together with holly and
tina suddenly angelo and his men come to his house
and ask him to go to maurice's house again right
now because he does not hit angelo's earlier offer
luckily there are holly and his neighbor
georgie to watch his little sister for the night
a few moments later the group manages to kidnap
maurice while he is walking with his girlfriend
after that an angry angelo orders beau
to chop off one of maurice's hands
although initially reluctant in the end he
cannot do anything but obey the order because
angelo threatens to harm his family including
holly the person who he loves most thus maurice
screams in pain very hysterically as bo leaves
the place unable to stand his own actions just now
thanks to his bravery angelo gives him a lot of
drugs packages after showing georgie the drugs
he plans to skim fifteen thousand dollars off the
money he makes from drug dealing so he and tina
can pay off the remaining debt and leave the
town in peace amazingly beau is able to sell
the drugs completely in five days only so he can
quickly give angela the rest of the money and asks
his permission to leave the job one morning after
holly and bo sleep together she asked him what has
happened to his hand from then on all his secrets
are revealed that he is deeply inspired by the
street magician he saw as a child he is taught by
the magician that a magician must perform tricks
that no one else can do except himself with
his skill in upgrading his tools he manages to
move or lift objects that are slightly larger and
heavier in size such as an iron chair that he can
move around a bit at night he goes to a party that
has been held by angelo everything is going well
until angelo invites beau to go upstairs and finds
out that beau was cheating on his drug packages
as the result he immediately threatens to
kill beau unless he can come up with 45 000
dollars in one week to pay angela back as a
result bo comes home with a bruised face he
also tells holly everything he is dealing with
luckily she continues to support him in making
money she even gives the rest of her savings to
help him long story short he works really hard
by selling the remaining drugs he has while
playing his tricks to make money even faster
feeling that he still needs more money he decides
to steal the last nine thousand dollars from luna
just in the right time luna invites him up to the
main office where her safe deposit box is located
beau uses the opportunity to watch her unlock
the safe deposit box studying the codes when
they want to leave the office he pickpockets
the office keys from her and then pretends to
go to the toilet for a while as luna walks out
first however he moves the security camera using
his power so he can return back to the office
unnoticed then stealing the money from the safe
deposit box he also manages to hide after a guard
suddenly enters the office to take things there
afterwards he has a final drink with luna feeling
guilty for stealing from her but relieved he was
out of his predicament alive after drinking with
her maurice's gang unexpectedly is at the club
at the same time when they spot him they managed
to knock him out handcuff him and eventually put
him in the trunk of a car fortunately he manages
to escape by using his electromagnet to lift the
latches on the handcuffs and trunk nevertheless
maurice has stolen all of his money in the process
at midnight bowen and his little sister
choose to live at their neighbor's house as
angelo and his men suddenly ran sackbo's house
to collect the money he asked for previously
the following day beau tells his sister to
go back to school because he thinks that
the situation is already conducive but it turns
out that angelo has told his men to kidnap tina
he finds out when angelo threatens him again
through the phone call from that moment beau has
no choice but to hand over the money he doesn't
have as soon as possible when he gets home he
suddenly remembers his old high school science
teacher he then decides to go to his teacher's
house and gets back in touch with him to get more
power to his electromagnet therefore the teacher
has an idea to add a feedback oscillator based on
his knowledge they finally managed to upgrade the
electromagnet but he warns both it may cause
the wires in his arm to overheat since then
those powers have reached the full potential just
like magneto in the x-men movies when he feels
he is ready he comes to angelo's house with holly
and tells her to wait outside he then goes inside
with the supplemented electromagnet to find out
where tina is he immediately rips out one of his
former co-workers gold teeth causing him to bleed
he also hits the other man with his own aluminium
bat and sends it flying into the wall not long
after angelo comes up to shoot him straight away
but what happens next is that he stops the bullets
and causes the lights to flicker he then drops the
bullets to the floor and picks one up slowly
burrowing it into angelo's forehead to force
him to divulge tina's whereabouts after angelo
tells beau that she is with his aunt he releases
the bullet from angelo's forehead and gives him
fifteen thousand dollars before leaving angrily
soon he instantaneously picks up tina who is
not far from there with his arm burned in the
end he chooses to start a new life peacefully
with holly and his little sister in san diego
as they are getting accustomed to their life
beau is still doing street magic with his new
trick and entertaining the people around for his
main job as his arm has now completely healed
lastly holly is startled by all the lights in
the house suddenly flickering by themselves
she then walks into the bathroom to check on bo
looks like he is developing a new trick from his
electromagnet that might just make him a superhero
in the town subscribe to watch more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for watching